*Strange noises*
No
Shit
Fuck
God dammit!
This video isn't 10 minutes yet
What the fuck do I do?!
It's fuckin' January
There's such a lack of Ad Revenue already!
I'm just gonna have to learn from the best
To extend this video to 10 minutes.
I'm talking slow
IS THAT OBVIOUS WHAT I'M DOING HEREEEEEE
OHHHH
Leafy!
Master of title cards
*You Reposted In The Wrong Neighorhood Music Plays*
Holy shit that's 11 seconds
WITH NO CONTENT!
Actually it's, never mind that that's 17 minutes
I'm just kid...
I'm kidding
I'm KIDDING
Calvin, I'm joking.
M'kay I get, I nee, I get it. I need an
I need an intro
I need to bring it back
ROLL
THE INTRO!
Are we at 10 minutes yet?
Fuck.
UGH
So just
So just suposed
Okay I got it!
CaseyNeistat
He does these transitional shots
LET'S HAVE A LOOK
Fuck, okay
Just roll a random,
A random ass...
Stock Image Footage, okay?
ARE WE AT TEN MINUTES YET
PLEASE?!
FUCKING
JANUARY
Do you see what happens with the Ad Revenue?!
This is bad. This is real bad
I'm gonna have to find a real job, real soon if this continues!
Oh, I got it!
I-In my last video, uh-
Eehhhh
Don't worry about the order in this vídeo, I know it's a little messy okay
*Pewds.exe stopped working of YouTube*
But into yesterday's video, I said I was gonna put the top comment
The top comment on that wall
Now I haven't checked, alright?
I have not checked.
So It could be anything right now
Let's... Let's see what it is.
Well I'm a bit nervous
That's the top comment? (yes)
I gave you guys, permission to put fucking anything
to put. fucking. ANYTHING.
In the background of my video
AND THE TOP COMMENT IS
A FUCKING SELF ADVERTISING.
i though at LEAST
I... I.. I taught you guys to learn better!
Than believe in some random ass fucking comment saying "I love you"
What the fuck does that mean?
If you had a homeless guy from the street tell you I love you
It doesn't mean anything, words don't mean SHIT.
unless it comes, with REAL MEANING
and from a person,
That you respect or at least know who the FUCK IT IS!
Now excuse me while i'm putting...
Let's just go back to what the video is about
I don't fucking give a shit
Hey, how's it going
Bros
Welcome to another original video idea
Try Not To Love #Laugh (ha)
i failed already
but there's a catch
since you guys love my moustache so much
thank you very much by the way (yes hello hitler)
i really appreciate all the nice feedback about my new appearance. you know
here, i was thinking i look cool
finally
i found a hip new look that fits me and my personality
but i guess that's not good enough
so if i laughed, i will shave a piece of my moustache
as much as it pains me
it pains my very core! (find your positive core message today)
and if i run out of moustache
i will shave this dog
(laughed)
rip edgar
let's do this
the first video
is chair. (Oh my god the chair!)
oh damn
(giggle)
it's just kind of video where you know you're gonna laugh even before you watch it
there's no way i could not have laughed at that
it's just a little piece
whatever...
think we all know where this is heading
i like it, is a good look, i really hope i don't have to laugh again
[v] have you ever done a sinus rinse before?
oh hello...okay...
i don't believe i'm -
OMG
(rerethinks life)
i need to do a sinus rinse right fucking now
ugh.
and i don't want the world to see me (sing)
didn't laugh
thank you very much
Next
what is this? what is he doing?
[v] shut your fucking mouth
[v] shut the fuck up you cunt
[v] shut it
oh..no..no..that was
an after giggle
they don't count
My Cat Is Crazy
*glass shattering sound* (cracking up)
i didn't laugh (oh yes u did)
*glass shattering sound*
No. 1, why were you filming...your cat in a fucking garden house?
No.2 ...
What the fuck. (laugh)
*glass shattering sound*
where did that cat go?
what was so important to that cat
why do i feel like i'm Ray William Johnson
deconstructing a fucking shit of-
au..we're getting there
i kinda like it
do you like it? ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
dat stare tho
(squelch)
(snort)
moving on
[v] we gonna interview Erik Weihenmayer who climbed the highest mountain in the world, Mount Everest. But-
ugh
[v] he's gay
[v] i mean he's gay, excuse me he's blind
[v] so we're here about that
*tries real fucking hard not to laugh*
i don't wanna laugh
ah for fuck...
[v] we gonna interview Erik Weihenmayer who climbed the highest mountain in the world, Mount Everest. But he's gay
but he's
gay
Girl Cries Like Racing Car
[v] hey sorry i missed your call
[v] ummm...
[v] i'm just calling you back to...
[v] uhhh...
[v] let you know that i...
oh no... [v] i love you
and i miss you
*girl crying sound like racing car*
(inhales loudly)
i really, i really want you to call me back
*crying*
and i'm sorry i missed your phone call
and i, i, aii...
i know you are DONE
so, so when you get this will you call me back
*crying*
i love you
and i miss you
*crying*
next video
Why Are You Watching That
[v] don't tell mommmmm
these are really good
these are really good clips this time
why were you watching that?
they are just blind, they are just blind, don't worry about it
there's nothing wrong watching blind people (oh the irony)
ummm...
early stages of a yaoi fan girl
(laugh)
fuck it
alright, it was worth it
it was worth it
oh no
[v] k...i wanna show you a little secret
oh!! okay...
[v]A guy taught me from the American Rangers
great
[v] and he always said, you know...
[v] in a tactical situation the sound of velcro
[v] you can hear a mile away
[v] and everybody knows that sound of velcro
that's true
[v] so here we have a velcro pouch
[v] and this is the sound that gives you a way in a tactical situation
[v] and
[v] so... he taught me
[v] a method of opening a velcro so that if you do that no one will hear the velcro- [pewds] i'm already laughing
okay, what is that?
[v] it's real fast, and, so the velcro i've got it on is the best i can get it on
is this suppose to be funny?- [v] and this is what he taught me
okay...
[v] AH!!! (wtf)
*laugh*
*Life Being Sucked Out Of Soul*....hahahaha
take your arm outward 45 degrees from the front and lift your arm up as far as-
here we go
i think is time
*shaving sound* *We Are Number One Plays* *dancing*
alright, well...
that was Try Not To Laugh Challenge moustache edition
if you enjoy this video
i think you're gonna enjoy
this one
this is the one you wanna watch next
so make sure you click right here
for another video
oh boy, is one of my favourite actually
what's that?
oh you already clicked
then why am i even here...?